As you might imagine, a straightforward
recursive implementation would involve
an unfortunate amount of recomputation,
so we'll look for a better solution.
Notice that it's natural to organize our
subproblems in a grid like this one.
Knowing C(3,3),
the cost of a line in the full sequence,
depends on knowing C(3,2),
C(2,2) and C(2,3).
Knowing C(2,3) depends on knowing
C(2,2), C(1,2) and C(1,3).
And indeed, in general,
to figure out any cost, we need to know
the cost to the west, to the northwest,
and to the north to fill out this grid.
These dependencies form
a directed acyclic graph, and
we can linearize them
in any number of ways.
We might do it in scan
line order like this.
Or in left to right fashion like this.
Or even maybe along
the diagonals like this.
We'll keep it simple and
go in scan line order.
First we need to fill out the base
cases, this first row and
this first column.
And then it's just a matter
of passing over the grid and
taking the minimum of the three
possibilities outlined earlier.
Once we've finished, we can retrace our
steps by looking at the west, north,
and northwest neighbors to
figure out what step we took.
And this, then, will allow us
to reconstruct the alignment.